this week conflict zone is a scope here
the capital of Macedonia a country in
crisis Macedonia would like to join the
European Union but it is backsliding in
the rule of law and has been wrecked by
a wiretapping scandal can Macedonia find
a way to give its people a future
Nikola papasa welcome to conflict zone
your country is a deep political crisis
earlier elections were now postponed
twice when our free and democratic
elections finally going to happen in
your country all they have happened for
more than 16 times since the
independence the crisis of the last
month you know you had to postpone in
April now you postponed in June so it's
very interesting that the country has to
postpone every four weeks week the
elections when will we have free
elections in this country the same
moment the biggest opposition party
would agree that they're happy to
participate in the elections the reason
why we have postponed these elections is
that we have agreed that we have
anticipated elections in April the
Social Democratic Party preferred to
have that later we have arranged for for
it to happen on 5th of June lastly they
have decided not to participate on that
it will have made sense to have
elections without the biggest opposition
but it's all the same very interesting
information and from the information
point you're right but let's talk about
the motives about all these parties you
your party didn't want it to postpone
the elections if the result of massive
demonstrations and the refusal of all
oppositional parties to participate
everybody was against the elections all
the you were not why actually the the
trigger for not having elections is the
fact that the biggest opposition party
decided not to participate everybody
else has said and I think that this is a
fair point
that it doesn't make sense to have
elections when your second biggest party
in the country and the biggest
opposition party does not want to
participate
therefore I wouldn't say that everybody
disagreed with the principle if you ask
all other political parties they will
tell you that they wanted to have June
5th elections but with everyone on board
it doesn't make sense to have them with
your ex demonstrations they per day
protesters they per day around the
streets when you enter the
industry you see a lot of colors what is
the problem in your country
demonstrations are not something
specific to Macedonia in our part of the
world I would fight for everyone to have
the right to demonstrate in this country
and unless we have that right preserved
it doesn't make sense to organize
anything which is going in the sense of
as a say that your party your party is
manipulating the election lists
demonstrators are saying that your party
is not giving a free access to the press
that you are manipulating the press the
oppositional parties are saying it's
ridiculous to have elections as long
this party is manipulating the
possibilities to have a free vote that's
why you have protesters if the majority
of the population in Macedonia was
sharing that to you I wouldn't have been
in government and this party you're
speaking about the actual times the last
month the last month the you told you
the same you have to take care about
democracy we can say also about today
and today still the people that are
demonstrating expressing these views we
do not represent the view of the
majority of the population if this was
the case the national parties and your
coalition partners say no to the
elections this is the majority of the
country they represent more than 51% why
didn't you respect that I say no to the
elections - so we all agree that we
shouldn't have elections on the fifth of
June you didn't postpone because you
wanted to postpone because you had -
that is not accurate I don't think that
I agree fully with your view that we
shouldn't have elections with one single
party but the reason for having
elections in June is because opposition
has been requesting to happen however
they share the same view as we have
which public opinion polls are
suggesting and that is that public
opinion is not favorable to the
opposition therefore what what is the
interest of an opposition party to hold
elections that they're asking for if
there is the likelihood of losing them
is very high
okay so let's speak about some other
things your country is being shaken up -
one scandal after another one exam
if the wiretapping scandal under the
form of Prime Minister who is
responsible for this scandal I think the
only one that can give a judgement on
that is a court according to the rule of
law when it is like that why is the
court not working well there is a
process they're also judgments that have
happened some of the people that have
been involved have been pardoned in the
meantime what has been happening is that
the leader of the biggest opposition
party came out in public and said Prime
Minister has been wiretapping everyone
in this country and he said I'm going to
show that and I'm going to broadcast
what he has broadcasted during this
series of press conferences when he was
producing or broadcasting illegally
wiretapped materials were conversations
of allegedly members of government
including the Prime Minister so the
legitimate question number one is how
did he add these materials number two if
he claims that the Prime Minister was
wiretapping then why is it broadcasting
all conversations that are allegedly we
will talk about including the World
Minister that was the Prime Minister
wiretapping himself that's a possibility
but up to 20,000 people were targeted by
your intelligence service members of
parliament opposition figures senior
civil servants journalists judges all
had the conversation recorded illegally
for years
that's hardly possible without
government knowledge isn't it if this is
the case then the one and only person
that has access to that information is
the one that was broadcasting you that
is the nature of the opposition a lot of
broadcasting a lot again how this is
possible in the country 20,000 people
without the knowledge of the government
without the government being involved
again it was the intelligence service
has it produced to prove that there were
20,000 people were dubbed the prime
minister at the time Nikola Gruevski
says the white tampering scandal created
and fabricated and edited by whom the
one that was producing that was the
leader of the biggest opposition party
mr. Sorenson accused
that the leader of the opposition party
had organized the wiretapping in this
country I don't know that I support who
did it by whom
was it done who is responsible the fact
is that the one that was producing
allegedly wiretap materials was the
leader of the Opposition so who was
responsible I mean this is a crisis of
the state when the government is why
attempt who was it
that is why I have answered that he has
the keys of giving the information of
who gave him the materials what has been
happening in the past period is that
there were court cases in which at least
three current and former officials of
the intelligence services have been on
trial
some of them sentence for the basic
reason of being or performing illegal
wiretaps this is what the court
decisions have been saying who produced
and who was responsible for this why it
happened there were clear answers on
that who well the fact was that there
was an illegal wiretapping that was
happening by some individuals in the in
the Lang in the intelligence services
know them well they have names they were
convicted I think at least one of them
active I think at least one of them is
convicted and at least two of them are
are in are in processing court you are
right
one person only one person was convicted
for this massive illegal surveillance
operation a low-level official of the
Minister of Interior and you know what I
don't know if you know but he has been
released a state court do you believe
that you can fool the public one person
is convicted for such a state scandal
well it's one more than the number of
persons that have been convicted in many
other wiretapping scandals around the
world that have happened one person and
he is released through do you want to
fool the public no I think this is
democracy I think that they should have
a fair access to information and that is
the fact that there are at least at
least 3 persons that are subject to
judicial proceedings I think we should
preserve
the assumption of innocence for the two
ones that are not moving yet three mr.
Minister I'm a lawyer there are three we
are speaking about wiretapping scandal
where the government is included a lot
of people like who the elite is included
and there were only three people
organizing this who was giving the
orders who are you covering for who is
responsible behind these three people
I mean scapegoats nothing else I don't
think that neither you nor me are
capable of giving sentences to people
who have been included in that the fact
is that investigation has shown that
people within the intelligence services
have been wiretapping government
officials including the Prime Minister
himself I want to talk about the
recorded conversations one of the tapes
Gordana uncle Oscar for material
Minister speaking to her colleague the
finance minister says quote one day we
will go to prison
for all that I don't think that anybody
would feel comfortable to show the
authenticity of this wiretap and I don't
think that anybody can comment on things
that are clearly taken out of context or
edited or context a minister of your
government is telling another Minister
of your government one day we will go to
prison for all this for what concern
frankly I haven't got a clue that she
said that and I wouldn't be able to
comment on something that I'm not even
convinced that person was convicted two
others are still whatever in
relationship to the justice
what is proved by these tapes you say no
it's not her do you say it was not her I
cannot make an assessment first all I'm
not an expert second of all I so hurt I
assume that you don't you don't
recognize the voice of your colleagues
you know what kind of things you can do
today with technology we just need to I
haven't got a clue you should ask the
ones that are producing so maybe mr.
zelf would know that okay because I do
think that's the finance minister zona
Stravinsky whose voice is on the same
Terrace was asked and has never denied
their authenticity well has he confirmed
does he I have you know I will tell you
something if I have a minister and I'm
in such a conversation and I'm asked
politically certainly I will deny
certainly I will tell to the public you
know what this is really a mess when
when a politician when the politician is
not saying that why not if any of us has
been wired up for five years during all
your phone conversations you can make
someone look like saying whatever you
want no I do whatever you want yeah mr.
Minister if it's true that she and the
government and these two ministers said
one day we will go to prison for all
this I don't know why she said but she's
speaking about a duty I think it's a
very strong assumption to make on a very
voting what was recorded yeah what was
recorded and what was produced to you by
someone who has completely different
political agenda that is the leader of
the Opposition okay so I will ask you
first so how did he get this word so why
did the opposition is not any judgment
conservative that's a very good question
and he is also on the list of
politicians that have been subject to a
presidential pardon okay since then has
pardoned a number of politicians across
the political voices let's speak about
that last month and other prominent
members but the majority of the pardon
came from your party President George
even of pardoned 56 people facing
criminal investigations and most of them
I repeated from your party what a
coincidence I think that there across
the political board you also have very
eminent politicians from the opposition
party let's party but that is not the
subject of of the discussion who and why
I think that one object it's a subject
you know let's look who was pardoned
okay the former Prime Minister the
former in tyrannous the former head of
intelligence all pardoned you should
know that all of them the names that you
have mentioned have requested to be
excluded from the presidential pardon
the former Prime Minister had to be
pardoned the former interior minister
had to be pardoned
the former head of intelligence that
means that before they were pardoned
investigations could have happened
yes why they didn't say I don't want to
be pardoned
it is precisely what happens actually
the former prime minister said to the
president I do not want to be pardoned I
want to be subject to the yes of course
I said that publicly but former head of
the Macedonian Constitutional Court
trendle even offski commented on the
pardons this is the lowest and the most
despicable thing that could have
happened as the former head of you
Macedonian Constitutional Court okay I
am not aware of the of the statement but
in a situation called we definitely did
sure that the statement is I take it I
kid I take it as a correct I will give
you my personal opinion I do not think
that presidential pardon was beneficial
if you ask me I do not think that it
should have happened it would have been
better for the country not to have it
however President of the Republic
according to the Constitution has right
to pardon his assessment was that the
political confrontation in the country
was so bitter and the things were so
much escalating in the latest period
that if he wouldn't intervene then he
wouldn't be held accountable from a
historic perspective because because of
no intervention after he pardoned the
political situation went worse the
population were fed up about all these
things I shared this assessment I think
it has worse than a political situation
so the president has to go away he
divided mistake for the country I do not
think because I think that the intention
was positive the consequences were very
negative and sometimes the road to hell
is paved with good intentions
one of you former ambassadors as in
Szekely said
after the pardons were announced that it
wasn't really surprising quote in a
country where it is common knowledge
that it has run by one political party
which means your party and were crime
crime and corruption flourish this
decision was to be expected I mean he's
talking also about your party corruption
crime it's fundamentally wrong at the
very basis this country is not run by
your own party it has never been run by
one party since the independence and
including party and now we have a very
large coalition and he was ending part
we are the leading party no government
RTC is talking about corruption crime he
could have said the same thing for the
last 25 years I guess you can say that
for the next 25 years because there will
be always this sort of challenges I
think that the assessment that one
should make is how much effort we do to
improve this situation because these
things are happening as much everywhere
including in the member states of the
European Union it depends on how we
fight it interesting only one question
you still want to join the European
Union
definitely okay so let's speak about the
European Union and what they are
believing what is happening here a
report for the European Commission last
year said the situation in Macedonia has
been backsliding achievements of the
last decades reforms are being
undermined by real and potential
political interference in the work of
the judiciary the chances of joining we
you are the crisis it is accurate one
should look into the reasons and one
should ask a legitimate question this
country has been candidate country since
2005 and has a recommendation to start
accession negotiations in 2009 that
means we're in the seventh year since
the European Commission has recommended
that we should start and European
Parliament has supported we've been
blocked in the console because Member
States did not agree with his
recommendation from the Commission and
now ask the question for how long can
you hold the country like Macedonia so
much dependent on the European future on
its neighbourhood in the limbo where it
has no predictability whatsoever on
starting accession negotiations on run
just a file that base is easy and then
give us no but there are deep reasons to
become a you remember one must accept
freedom of prayer
and freedom of speech the you Commission
States attempts to limit media reporting
on matters of public interest are
worrying
why are you suppressing the media you
can't be a member of the European Union
and suppress the media I think that
there are several nuances that need to
be made there if you say that there is
no freedom of speech in this country I
will hardly dispute that because you can
say pretty much everything where
everyone can write whatever they want
there is feedback it's otherwise so when
we're speaking affect the index of press
freedoms published annually by reporters
without borders ranks Mustard oh yeah
118 in the world below Nigeria Oh Qatar
aren't you ashamed it says a lot also
about the methodology of grading people
countries it's based on experts
assessments very often has a political
bias and I strongly disagree with the
assessment that Macedonia has lower
freedom of speech rating than some of
the countries that you quoted and
probably even more that are above us it
is a political assessment it is a
deficiency that we definitely have in
the area of media polarization and
people taking sides so this is something
that we need to tackle seriously and it
is the responsibility of the government
when they are not the only one pitiful
who to retired you mediator said to
Dodgeville in March I'm shocked by the
current situation the atmosphere
suppression of freedom that's what you
call democracy well first of all it's
good also to take a distance from some
of the sources because he used to be a
mediator that is no longer a mediator
because of taking political sites in
this bottle which is one of the things
that one should not do and he wants to
be back to Athens explain honest broker
met with his experience he decided to
make a statement says all the quotes
from anybody everybody whatever are not
correct as I'm not representing the
truth can it be that they are
representing the truth but you don't
want to admit that it is like that I'm
taking at the face value of what you're
saying so if you're telling me that
there is a
major fear in our society on saying or
publishing things how does it happen
in this country that you have hundreds
of statements and and positions that are
extremely critical to the government
so one should pick a thesis either we
have complete suppression of freedom of
speech and then you will only hear
positive things about us which is not
accurate we're not talking about
complete a little bit in the democracy
is even too much
okay well freedom is not a little bit
being pregnant there is freedom of
speech there is freedom of press or
there is not I agree and I would buy
your argument however we should go in
the real world and check what is the
Macedonia's position compared to peers
in the region and to member states of
the European Union so if you ask me that
freedom of speech in Germany and Sweden
is more expressive and easier to define
then it is in the Balkans I buy that
argument if you're telling me that
Macedonia is war stuff then some of the
peers in the region not some but all of
them including those that are in the
European Union that's not true do we
agree both that Macedonia has to improve
the things fully agree okay that's I buy
that you will need to agree we need to
agree and we agree that we agree but
let's talk about the tense of and we
will improve I'm pretty sure about it
because there are a lot of very
interested on that but let's talk about
the tens of thousands of refugees camped
on the fair side of your border to
Greece on March 11th this year you were
quoted in The Jerusalem Post we are
willing to give them humane treatment
and safe transit are you treating the
refugees that's people humanely every
single refugee that has rich Macedonian
territory has been treated humanely
and safely and this will continue to
happen and the rest on the borders two
weeks earlier two weeks before you
showed that to the world on February
29th of this year Macedonian police
fired tear gas and stun grenades at
refugees you call that humane one should
also
say what happened at that day we had
literally an invasion of several
hundreds of young male individuals that
used violence to cross illegally a state
border with Germany tolerate that I'm
getting celebrated that no not the
violence there was no borders rubber
bullets they were never tear gas and
because you are saying adults hello
stammers of myths and some frontier said
that there were also children forces
used rubber bullets against children
that's you main treatment this is
something that one needs to confirm
because from the reporting that we have
received there were no rubber bullets
uses at that border incident there was
tear gas and they were definitely police
forces that were preventing from massive
illegal crossings the major problem is
that Austria would never allow for such
a thing to happen which has happened to
us from a Greek territory because you
had 20 thousands of migrants stucked in
tents left at the borderline but then it
is slightly to use violence to cross the
border does this legitimate to use
chemicals rubber bullets stand grenades
it is very illegitimate to attack
Macedonia for doing what is it requested
by the European Union if you ask about
Macedonian political decision-making for
us the cheapest and the most efficient
thing would be simply to open up borders
put big panels make indication north and
then send people where they want to be
violence did you hide it to take another
way can you defend this decision with
chemicals we decided to do what we want
to do because we want to join European
Union and we want to be part of a
European answer and it helps Greece it
helps Germany it helps all the countries
on the transit route because all the
negative things that you're mentioning
are happening on Macedonian territory
and we are the only border where
refugees and migrants are leaving
European Union in order to join a
country that is not part of the European
Union why would we fight the battle of
others conscious lest we want to
consistent
the European women mistake I apologize
children never III don't think that
anybody should be even thinking about it
but what has happened is not what you
have described children have been never
subject to violence and what has
happened literally is young male
individuals using force to cross
illegally the border Macedonian police
could have spent the weekend on legs
lakeside and just observed migrants who
will reach Munich sooner we decided that
this is not an option because European
Council said that we need to resettle
people solution to that is that we take
these people in tents from the border
and we put them in the reception centers
for which European Union has paid a
member maaske thank you very much for
joining conflicts thank you very much
for the invitation
you